der super kannst du vielleicht sagen
oder pot ist darunter
ich sehe es ganz gut sein
herzlich willkommen zu diesem video
leute ich bin heute wieder am start für
euch denn sehr viele von euch haben sich
auf instagram da ist übrigens gesagt was
wir nicht folgt sollten wir da ein ganz
spezielles video gewünscht eine sache
wie ich noch sagen ich habe jetzt heute
einen neuen pc bekommen richtig geil das
heißt in zukunft werden
streams wiederkommen also haltet die
augen offen ich gebe euch der pension
bescheid wie gesagt und jetzt gehen wir
direkt los mit der folge der asi könig
von hilf mir
[Musik]
einige vielleicht denken sie jetzt über
mein gold das würde gestellt ich denke
da allein kunden von mir okay ich sag's
erstmal ich sage was ich denke diese
wenn ich denke da an einen ganz
speziellen formiert bevor ich den namen
sage und jeder selbst abdecken könnte
wäre ich dazu sagen nein
norman wissen nicht ganz auf diesem
level aber also der kopf erinnert schon
krass dran und also passt ja auch ganz
gut ich hätte ein bild von normen
einhalte
das war mein erster gedanke bei der
ganzen sache hier das ist schon wieder
zu viel viel wichtiger schritt auf dem
balkon ist beharrt man muss wirklich
sagen wie ein wolf ist eigentlich
eigentlich eher ein wolfsmensch als nazi
könig und dann kommt seine alte auf dem
balkon gibt ihm erstmal in den den rest
wird über den kopf als ihr sohn oder wie
sieht denn nicht aus wieso mitte zwanzig
oder dreißig oder so man muss an dieser
stelle allerdings dazu sagen leute diese
art von verhalten von müttern ist nicht
ganz ungewöhnlich so dass mütter sehr
kreativ und gemein werden wenn man die
die haushaltsregeln ich erfolgreich
sauberkeit angeht ich habe mal kann ich
mal erzählen das ist eigentlich eine
weile lang wie ab und zu mal so ein
zahnstocher herumliegen lassen hat so
einfach dann schauen wir uns vergessen
wegzuwerfen
warum hat meine mutter den einfach mal
in mein sitzpolster reingesteckt so
senkrechte nach dem motto ja vielleicht
setze sich jahr ein
es gibt das gefühl meine eigene mutter
ich bin nicht mehr reicht es ist vom
alter her wirklich nicht eindeutig ob
sie jetzt der mutter ist aber seine
freunde aber okay sie ist deine mutter
die harrys karine das schockt das
schockiert mich schockiert euch ja auch
leute dann dieser anblick pro also da
muss man wirklich etwas dagegen machen
so nicht
wo kämen wir somit gleich zwei dinge die
man hier an dieser stelle sagen muss
erstens welcher mensch schüttet ein bier
bevor es auf machte da fällt schon auf
dass diese story von menschen
geschrieben wurde die kein bier trinken
kein mensch
wir schütteln das geht überhaupt nicht
man würde sie könig erwarten dass er
weiss über ein bier auf macht aber aber
leute vielleicht hat das auch extra
geschüttet um seine seine mutter was zu
machen
ist nur ist eine gute reaktion heute auf
jeden fall kann man kann an der stelle
zu machen meist junger sohn der noch bei
seiner mutter im haushalt wohnt ja wenn
wenn deine mutter einfach nervt und der
besagt dass den müll raus bringen soll
ist was er an sich schon mal eine
bodenlose frechheit dazu wann wir wissen
dass so was nicht geht kann man
natürlich auch mal seine eigene mutter
mit bier übergießen
[Musik]
was für eine kreatur und ich will angst
ich habe angst haben nicht in paktia
er ist ja auch riesig große pläne hat
eben gesehen wahrscheinlich dass zwei
meter groß kommt zum zwei meter 120 kilo
yeti muss man eigentlich sagen ist es
eigentlich geht mit sechs dosen bier in
der hand auf dich zu uns besorgt was
machst du da es benehmen seiner mutter
gegenüber ist beschämend
es scheint ihm vollkommen egal zu sein
wie er sich gegenüber verhält jallohs
leben als yetis nicht leicht das leben
als yeti unter menschen ist das ist
tatsächlich nicht einfach wisst ihr wie
es ist wirklich kein körperbehaarung wie
ein mama wolfrum zu laufen ist ihr seid
wirklich quasi ihr seid ein braunbär
inspiriert kannst du bist kannst du mir
schon geben davon oder alsono front an
alle leute die dieses level 1
körperbehaarung haben aber dicker das
ist ich bin wirklich schockiert dass ihr
das tape ist eine art ist ein bisschen
wie eine freakshow weiter dann auch noch
so eine haltung
es sei von werwolf ich habe gerade bier
mitgebracht
fällt das 1 1 bis zum ja ja klar will
ich meine er sagt er hat bei uns
gegessen er für dieses wirklich es
braucht jetzt essen so durst das sieht
hier von ihm quasi ausgeliehen um ein
bisschen davon zu nehmen er will auch
immer noch auf drei sekunden nachdem er
gesagt hat das essen will will das immer
noch essen klingt überraschend dabei ist
jetzt mal im ernst ich wäre dafür geräte
seien von dem aber nein das ich weiß das
wird in lauffen glaube ich nicht machen
dann ist auch schon das auch schon gut
ich würde sagen was ich sage so vor
allem ist es ein bisschen seiner seite
aber der ist ja in erster linie vom as i
könig ja jetzt schilder und trägt man da
kommt ein bisschen klares lust hast du
aber noch nicht mehr lange warum das
wort erwähnt weil sie drei minuten da
die ich gerne sich literally vor einer
minute getroffen es ist wirklich nicht
mehr als einer minute sah ja leute ich
kann nicht mehr so lange wir haben jetzt
schon 60 sekunden ihren park verbracht
muss los oder gar nicht die wahrheit ist
es klar auch der der asse könig der yeti
der wolfsmensch ist selbstverständlich
auch bei der damenwelt ganz hoch im kurs
kann man glaube ich verstehen einerseits
wenn man sein verhalten sieht das
verhalten an den tag legt komplett
asozial und diszipliniert das gepaart
mit dem aussehen von einem braunbären
mit einem leichten haltung schaden da
spielt die damenwelt einfach verrückt
kann ich nicht so stehen lassen so nicht
mehr aber im ernst finden habt ihr habt
ja auch so den eindruck dass so seinen
kopf nicht zu seinem körper passt guck
mal schaue ich mir dieses bild dann wenn
man hier einfach so so photoshop möchte
ich einfach den kopf wieso abtrennen
würde und auf den anderen körper machen
weil das würde besser passen oder bei
perfect gestutzter bad und dann unten
drunter geht so die komplette werwolf
action ab aber erst mal trinken wir ein
paar geile party das kranke turner
weiter zu viert in einem park vor so
einem vertrackten gemauerten gebäude
zusteht
das wild das weniger es ist zu will
ich kann auch erwarten würde na was denn
los komm schon dass irgend so ein ding
bei den anderen nicht dabei zusehen wie
sie irgendwas essen er muss dann auch im
reinweißen das ist schon ein bisschen
krankhaft also man kann ja nicht 20
minuten später direkt nach dem einem
park waren wieder zu hause ist nicht
schon wieder hunger haben das geht ja
nicht
es muss wirklich einfach sein er hat
einfach ein spaß dran an den leuten was
weg zu essen das nicht zu machen
das ist wirklich nicht zu machen das ist
es ist zu viel
außerdem möchte in der wohnung dieselben
rechte haben wie seine eltern dann muss
aber dieser im rechte ja dass das ist
eine gute analyse er möchte hat
dieselben rechte haben
das ist das worum es hier geht
eigentlich entsteht einfach nur für
seine eigenen rechte als bürger nicht
als bürger als bewohner dieser wohnung
ein
geht nicht darum dass er seine mutter
komplett maut oder eine fristlose
kündigung vom anwalt an keiner stelle
irgendwo auf diesem schreiben ist
irgendwie so ein briefkopf vom anwalt im
namen von anwalt.de anschrift nein es
ist der undercover anwalt der bleibt
einfach undercover hiermit kündigen wir
fristlos ihren mietvertrag wirtshaus
folge gründen und ordnung im zimmer das
ist rechtlich sicher leute dass es
einfach einwandfrei garantiert von dem
anwalt gemacht worden
das ganze wieder so weiter leute dass er
von seinen eltern rausgeschmissen wird
endlich der im smi geschafft irrenhaus
yeti aus der wohnung raus zu befördern
und das jetzt natürlich was macht er
zieht natürlich zu den zu den eltern von
seiner freundin in deren wohnung diese
natürlich entsprechend erfreut
ja das war damals ein der super kannst
du vielleicht sagen oder potters ich das
ganz gut sein ja ok ok wurde formal
nicht mehr von heute doch ich habe an
der stelle genug vom heutigen treu
beobachten leute ich denke mal die auch
ihr kriegt ja hier und dann für euch
vorstellungsvideo ungemein karen ich bin
alleine schon daraus macht gut und